Isis claims responsibility for the
murder of four Western tourists
including an American couple in
Tajikistan Jay Austin and Morgan Loren
giggin from Washington DC died in the
car and knife attack
chip Reid looks at the two Americans who
were far from home on their bicycles
Shep good morning
well good morning a little more than a
year ago Jay Austin and Lauren Gagan
both just 29 years old quit their
comfortable office jobs in Washington
and set out for an adventure traveling
the world by bicycle sadly their ride
ended in tragedy in the mountains of
Tajikistan Jay Austin and Lauren Gagan
chronicled their adventures on their
website simply cycling as they pedaled
their way through Africa Europe and
Central Asia Austin wrote they chose to
see the world by bike because life is
short and the world is big and we want
to make the most out of our youth and
good health before they're gone they
were both just the kind of people that
you wanted to open your heart to Molly
Scalise was gegen friend and roommate
they were the most kind empathetic
principles people that I knew the
couple's dream ended suddenly Sunday in
Tajikistan near the border with
Afghanistan when terrorists ran into
their group with a car and then attacked
them with knives they were killed along
with two Europeans and three other
Europeans were injured Taji Cathar DS
say police tracked down five of the isis
suspects killing four of them on their
blog austin had written of the
challenges of their trip writing bikes
create the expectation that disaster is
pretty much inevitable and should be
embraced but he also wrote it was a
privilege to see some amazing places
meet some wonderful people and spend
lots and lots of time with a really
lovely girl they were such an example of
a intentional life and a principled life
and had so much love to give and i'm
glad that they had the opportunity to to
bring that to so many people around the
world the State Department has offered
assistance but the investigation is
being led by Tajikistan's mother told us
over the phone her son was a gentle soul
who simply wanted to leave the world a
better place
Anthony chip Reed thank you chip